i was 13 when i said i want to be the
best doctor in the world
you know so i said it to my mom and
because my mom agreed with it
and then that created the vibration of
accomplishing right
then when i was 21 that's when i said
mom i'm leaving where are you going i'm
going to america i'm going to go
because you know i have to be old enough
enough for my mom to let me go
and so that's when i moved to the border
and that's when it took me two weeks to
jump the border
and then i was homeless for two months
after i closed the border
but it's that vibration is that that
focus that vision that trust
i didn't speak english i didn't know
anybody i didn't have an address i
didn't i didn't have money
we come from low income family but my
point to the world
is that if you connect to that vibration
and then
whatever you want in life comes comes
free so if your goal is to have a dog to
walk off leash
just connect to that vibration because
i'm going to tell you how i chose the
coyote
so you have a spirit of spiritual
coyotes you have emotional coyotes and
you have
physical coyotes so when you jump the
border you
you you have to hire somebody because
you i didn't know
you know anything about america i heard
another it was just a dream
i needed to go to america and i hadn't
any family i didn't speak addre
english and my dad gave me a hundred
dollars that was his life savings
okay so at two weeks i wanted to keep
the hundred dollars i had it in my my
between my
my sock and my and my shoe and
for two weeks i i that's what i did
jump jump jump jump jump jump jump and i
get caught every single time every
single time
and then one day this guy comes skinny
guy smoke
joint dirty skinny everything my mom
said not to follow
something inside of me and say follow
him and the guy said i charge you a
hundred dollars
who send it you know what i mean then on
top of that watch this
we crossed the border and he said well
you have to have a tax you have to catch
a taxi
so you can take you to san diego because
it's just the border right there san
ysidro right there
and they say i don't have any more money
after this the guy
paid the taxi
the guy paid twenty dollars wow that's
and that's when when i wrote my first
book
i i said the angels that you can see
yeah
you know what i mean the second was jada
pinka smith right because she paid
for me to learn english that's how i
learn english
wow so i so with my broken english at
that time i told jayda
you know i would like to have a tv show
or radio because i want to teach people
right i saw the need of teaching right
so i never teach before
i then came to america to teach but i
felt free and comfortable to tell jada
i would like to have a tv show or a
radio show well for that you need to
speak english
the next day a teacher came for a year
so i can learn english
those are angels that you can see
absolutely yeah without a doubt
without a doubt but i'm not here because
it's just me i'm here because
i follow that voice you know
and and uh and i'm i'm my fate is
super big the beautiful part about being
poor
is that you pray every day because
government doesn't help you
so god is the only one who's going to be
there you love the family to death
and you work hard so my instincts high
level
my love high level my faith high level
so that's
that's what pushed me so you're not poor
anymore do you still pray
of course yeah really because i want
world transformation